This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Say kids, what time is it? Howdy Doody Time! It's Howdy Doody Time! It's Howdy Doody Time! If your parents or grandparents grew up in the United States in the 1950s, there's a decent chance that you have heard them sing this song. And if you're the right age, you can probably sing it yourself. In fact, if you're a boomer, it might be stuck in your head right now.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。孩子们，请问几点了？该看《豪迪·杜迪时间》了！《豪迪·杜迪时间》到了！《豪迪·杜迪时间》到了！如果你的父母或祖父母是在 20世纪 50年代的美国长大的，你很有可能听他们唱过这首歌。如果你年龄合适，你大概也能自己唱。事实上，如果你是婴儿潮一代，这首歌现在可能还盘旋在你的脑海里。
In which case, I am sorry. For those who don't know, this nearly atonal chanting is the theme song to one of the very first children's television programs, the Howdy Doody Show. As reporter and long-time 99PI contributor, David Weinberg. The Howdy Doody Show is one of those pieces of 1950s ephemera, like the hula hoop, that has come to symbolize mid-century American childhood. For over a decade, every weeknight at 5 p.m., kids all across the country would sit down
如果是这样的话，我感到很抱歉。对于那些不知道的人来说，这段近乎无调的吟唱是美国最早的儿童电视节目之一《豪迪·杜迪秀》的主题曲。正如记者兼长期 99PI 撰稿人大卫·温伯格所说，《豪迪·杜迪秀》是 20世纪 50年代的众多昙花一现的事物之一，就像呼啦圈一样，已经成为上世纪中期美国童年的象征。十多年来，每周一到周五晚上 5 点，全国各地的孩子们都会坐下来
in front of their parents' tiny television and take in the wild west adventures of Buffalo Bob and his Marionette puppet sidekick, Howdy Doody. Howdy, what do you think we ought to do? Well, I don't know, Mr. Smith, but I guess everybody likes movies. And now why don't we show a movie now? Bet you the rabbit. At the time, there wasn't anything quite like it. Imagine a singing cowboy performing a puppet show for your birthday, only five nights a week.
在父母的小电视机前，观看水牛比勃和他的牵线木偶搭档豪迪·杜迪的狂野西部冒险。豪迪，你觉得我们该做点什么？嗯，我不知道，史密斯先生，不过我想每个人都喜欢看电影。现在我们为什么不放映一部电影呢？我敢打赌是那只兔子。当时，没有什么节目能与之相比。想象一下，一个唱歌的牛仔在你的生日那天为你表演木偶戏，而且一周有五天都是如此。
And now imagine nearly every other kid in America enjoying the same party at the same time. For a lot of children, it was their first encounter with the concept of a TV star. Which is why Bert Dubrow can remember exactly where he was when he first heard the rumor. I was out on a playground in fifth or sixth grade, Trinity School in New Rochelle, New York, and some kid said that Buffalo Bob bought a liquor School in New Rochelle, New York. And some kid said that Buffalo Bob bought a liquor store in New Rochelle. Now that would be like saying Mr. Rogers owned a liquor store. It didn't make any sense.
现在想象一下，美国几乎所有其他孩子都在同一时间享受着同样的派对。对许多孩子来说，这是他们第一次接触电视明星的概念。这就是为什么伯特·杜布罗能清楚地记得他第一次听到这个传言时的情景。当时我在五年级或六年级的操场上，那是纽约州新罗谢尔的三一学校，有个孩子说水牛比勃买了一家酒。纽约州新罗谢尔的三一学校。有个孩子说水牛比勃在新罗谢尔买了一家酒。这就像说罗杰斯先生开了一家酒馆一样。这根本说不通。
This happened back around 1960. And at the time, Bert loved all things TV, especially live TV, and especially Howdy Doody. So when he heard this rumor that the show's host, Buffalo Bob, was selling liquor in New Rochelle, he couldn't stop thinking about it. And I literally found the route from the south end to the north end,
这件事发生在 1960年前后。当时，伯特热爱电视节目，尤其是现场直播的电视节目，尤其是《豪迪·杜迪》。因此，当他听到传言说节目的主持人水牛比勃在新罗谢尔卖酒时，他脑子里一直挥之不去这个念头。我真的找到了从南端到北端的路线，
and I did not tell my parents. And I got in the M-Bus, and I got on the M-bus and I got off and those big signs said, Lickers. Ten years old, I walked into the liquor store. My chin came up to the counter and I said, excuse me, is Buffalo Bob here? And there was a man behind the counter who was wearing a check shirt, black cornroom glasses and said, I'm Buffalo Bob. Well that made no sense to me because he didn't look like Buffalo Bob, he didn't
而且我没有告诉父母。我上了 M 路公交车，我上了 M 路公交车，然后我下来了，那些大招牌上写着：Lickers（酒类专卖店）。十岁的我走进了那家酒馆。我的下巴刚好够到柜台，我说，请问水牛比勃在吗？柜台后面有一个男人，穿着格子衬衫，戴着黑色硬纸板眼镜，他说，我就是水牛比勃。这让我觉得莫名其妙，因为他看起来一点也不像水牛比勃，他也没有
did that second sound like Buffalo Bob, and he reached down below the counter and he pulled out a color picture that went right over there in the red frame and signed it to me. And as he was talking, he started to sound like Buffalo Bob. That's when Burt realized that this was really happening. He was standing in front of his hero, the actual living, breathing Buffalo Bob, selling liquor.
那个声音听起来像水牛比勃吗？他把手伸到柜台下面，拿出一张彩色照片，直接贴在那边的红框里，并在上面签了我的名字。当他说话时，声音开始变得像水牛比勃了。就在那时，伯特意识到这一切都是真的。他正站在他的偶像面前，那个活生生的、真正的主持人水牛比勃正在卖酒。
So now I went home, my parents were ready to kill me. Where were you? So I was at Buffalo Bob's liquor store. Well, they thought I was smoking something. But every day, or many days after that, I went. It reached a point that the people that worked for Bob at the liquor store, if they saw me coming through the big glass windows, Bob would run in the back. So he didn't have to see me. Bird Dubrow was not wrong to be starstruck. It's hard to overstate just how massive a
于是我回到家，我父母准备宰了我。你上哪儿去了？我说我在水牛比勃的酒馆里。好吧，他们以为我抽了什么违禁品。但在那之后的每一天，或者很多天，我都去了。到了后来，在酒馆里为比勃工作的那些人，如果看到我透过大玻璃窗走过来，比勃就会跑到后面去。这样他就不用见到我了。伯特·杜布罗崇拜偶像并没有错。很难夸大
cultural juggernaut Howdy Doody was. The show was disproportionately important to the history of television. It was the first television program to reach 1,000 episodes, one of the first shows to be broadcast in color, and it pioneered new ways of marketing products to children. All of which, while I was talking to Burt, begged the question. When I was doing the show on Saturday mornings and then running the liquor store the rest of the week, that's crazy. It made sense for him to buy the liquor store, let's just say that. It was just an investment. If it seems strange that the star of one of the most successful programs on television needed a side hustle. Well, today it would be.
《豪迪·杜迪》的文化巨轮有多么庞大。该节目对电视史具有非凡的重要性。它是第一个达到 1000 集的电视节目，是首批彩色转播的节目之一，并且开创了向儿童营销产品的新方式。所有这些，当我和伯特交谈时，引发了一个问题。当我周六早上一边做节目，一周中剩下的时间一边经营酒馆时，这太疯狂了。买下酒馆对他来说是有意义的，我们姑且这么说吧。这只是一笔投资。如果一个电视收视率最高的节目的明星还需要兼职，这听起来很奇怪。嗯，放到今天确实很奇怪。
But in the early days of the medium, especially when Howdy Doody first started, the world of television was strange. It was a place where no one knew what anything or anyone was worth, not even Buffalo Bob. And honestly, the fact that he ran a liquor store isn't even the strangest part. In many ways, the story of Howdy Doody is the story of the weird Wild West days of early TV. A story in which programmers, advertisers, artists, and money men were inventing everything as they went along.
但在电视媒介的早期，尤其是《豪迪·杜迪》刚开播时，电视世界是个陌生的地方。这是一个没有人知道任何东西或任何人价值几何的地方，连水牛比勃也不知道。老实说，他经营一家酒馆甚至还不是最奇怪的部分。在很多情况下，《豪迪·杜迪》的故事就是早期电视疯狂的西部片时代的故事。在这个故事中，节目制作人、广告商、艺术家和金主们在边走边发明一切。
Starting with what to put on television in the first place. After all, the very first TV shows, including Howdy Doody, had no prior TV shows to build on. Instead, they had to steal their programming ideas from other, older mediums, including the greatest medium of all. This is music historian Stephen Davis being interviewed by Terry Gross in 1987. His dad worked on Howdy Doody and he says that Buffalo Bob Smith got his name from his hometown of Buffalo, New York and his life in entertainment started early.
首先要决定在电视上播放什么。毕竟，包括《豪迪·杜迪》在内的最早的电视节目没有任何先例可循。相反，他们不得不从其他更古老的媒介中窃取节目创意，包括最伟大的媒介。这是音乐史学家斯蒂芬·戴维斯于 1987 年接受特里·格罗斯采访时的情景。他的父亲曾在《豪迪·杜迪》工作，他说水牛比勃·史密斯的名字来源于他的家乡纽约州水牛城，他的娱乐生涯开始得很早。
By the time he was four years old, Bob could recreate any melody he heard by plinking away on a piano with his two tiny fingers. And by the time he was in his 30s, he was a popular radio DJ. He hosted his shows sitting at a piano where he would sing along to records, perform comedy sketches, and read the weather. And originally, his sidekick's name was not Howdy Doody. Howdy's original name was Elmer, and he appeared on a Saturday morning quiz show that Buffalo Bob did in those days on the NBC radio network.
早在四岁时，比勃就能用两根小手指在钢琴上弹奏出他听过的任何旋律。到了三十多岁时，他已经是一位受欢迎的电台 DJ 了。他坐在钢琴旁主持节目，一边跟着唱片唱歌，一边表演喜剧小品，还播报天气。最初，他的搭档不叫豪迪·杜迪。豪迪最初的名字叫埃尔默，他出现在水牛比勃当时在国家广播公司（NBC）电台网络上主持的一个周六早晨问答节目中。
On the show, Bob developed the persona of Buffalo Bob, but he also voiced other characters, including Elmer, who back then was a kind of country bumpkin. And he had this really dumb kind of yokel voice, which kept saying, Howdy Doody, boys and girls. That was what the Elmer voice sounded like, kind of a rub, a cowboy, you know, somebody from the frontier, a rough dude, so to speak. And eventually, that became his name, Howdy Doody.
在节目中，比勃塑造了水牛比勃的银幕形象，但他也为其他角色配音，包括埃尔默，当时埃尔默是一个类似乡村乡巴佬的角色。他有一种非常愚蠢的乡下腔调，一直在说：“豪迪·杜迪，各位少男少女。”这就是埃尔默的声音听起来的样子，有点粗野，一个牛仔，你知道的，来自边境的人，可以说是一个粗犷的家伙。最终，这就成了他的名字，豪迪·杜迪。
And in a slightly alternate universe, Howdy would have disappeared from cultural memory when Bob's radio program went off the air. But mass media, and Buffalo Bob's show in particular, were about to undergo a huge change, thanks to the failure of television. After the first television sets became commercially available in the 30s, for a long time, well into the 40s,
在另一个略有不同的平行宇宙中，当比勃的广播节目停播时，豪迪本会从文化记忆中消失。但是大众传媒，尤其是水牛比勃的节目，即将在电视失败的推动下经历巨大的变革。在 20世纪 30年代第一台电视机投入商业使用后，在很长一段时间里，一直延续到 40年代，
the medium actually had a hard time catching on. For starters, unlike radio, which had a huge variety of shows, there wasn't much to watch on these small, grainy black and white screens. So in the early days of television, when they didn't have much programming, basically what they often did was just borrow the popular radio show of the time and move it to TV.
这种媒介实际上很难流行起来。首先，与拥有丰富节目的广播不同，这些小巧、颗粒感十足的黑白屏幕上并没有多少内容可看。因此，在电视早期的日子里，当他们没有太多节目时，通常的做法就是借用当时流行的广播节目并将其搬上荧幕。
This is Stephen Stark. I wrote a book about television and I'm a poet. I write poetry now. So yeah, that's what I do. Did you ever write any poems about Howdy Doody? No, I never wrote a poem about Howdy Doody, nor will I ever. Stephen says that when televisions first were on the market, few people could afford one. In 1948, very few people had televisions. We're talking fewer than a million people.
这是斯蒂芬·斯塔克。我写过一本关于电视的书，我是一名诗人。我现在写诗。所以，是的，这就是我的工作。你写过关于豪迪·杜迪的诗吗？不，我从来没有写过关于豪迪·杜迪的诗，以后也永远不会。斯蒂芬说，当电视机刚上市时，很少有人买得起。1948 年，极少数人拥有电视机。我们说的是不到一百万人。
And it was not yet a nationwide medium. Most of the early television stations were in New York, and those first broadcast signals didn't reach all that far. So nearly everyone who did own a TV lived in the New York area. So what you tended to get in the early days of television were shows that were very New York. I mean, loud, in your face. Take off your clothes, I wanna examine you.
它还不是一个全国性的媒介。早期的电视台大多在纽约，最初的广播信号也传不了那么远。因此，几乎所有拥有电视的人都住在纽约地区。所以在电视早期的日子里，你往往会看到非常具有纽约特色的节目。我的意思是，喧闹、直接。脱下你的衣服，我要检查你。
Take off your clothes. Oh, I couldn't take off my clothes. A lot of slapstick, chaotic. Some strange cameras here. Milton, pull off your pants. Sit down. And the number one television show in the early days of the medium
脱下你的衣服。哦，我不能脱下我的衣服。很多滑稽剧，混乱。这里有一些奇怪的摄像机。弥尔顿，脱掉你的裤子。坐下。而当时收视率最高的电视节目
was Milton Berle's show, Texaco Star Theater, which was essentially a New York Vaudeville show transferred to television. You wanna go on television every week? Yeah. Yes, but there's one important thing I must tell you, must tell you Danny, you gotta have gimmicks. What gimmicks?
是弥尔顿·伯le 的节目《德士古星光剧院》，这本质上是一个被搬上电视的纽约杂耍秀。你想每周都上电视吗？是的。是的，但有一件重要的事情我必须告诉你，我必须告诉你丹尼，你得有噱头。什么噱头？
A gimmick, running gags that you gotta do every week. They not? Like the Celts a bit. Oh no, no Celts. Yeah, the Celts a bit. Oh please, no. You take the Celts down. No, no, no.
噱头，你每周都得做的连环笑料。不是吗？像凯尔特人一点。哦不，不，凯尔特人。是的，凯尔特人一点。哦，拜托，不要。你把凯尔特人拿下来。不，不，不。
No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. No, let's go. Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah!
不，不，不。不，不，不。不，不，不。不，不，不。不，不，不。不，不，不。不，不，不。不，我们走吧。啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！
Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah!
啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！
Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Lone Ranger and The Shadow couldn't be adapted for live television. Even if they could playback recorded video. In the 1940s, no one in the industry was ready to invest those kinds of resources.
啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！《独行侠》和《影子》无法改编为电视直播。即使他们可以播放录制好的视频。在 20世纪 40年代，业内没有人愿意投入这种资源。
As a result, there was so little programming being made for television that for a long while there wasn't anything on before dinnertime. And I don't mean there wasn't anything on like it was boring. I mean there was literally nothing on. The TV networks only broadcast after 7 p.m. But then, in 1947, NBC found something new to put on the air by borrowing a different trick from the Vaudevillian playbook, puppets.
因此，为电视制作的节目少之又少，以至于很长一段时间里，晚饭前什么都没有。我并不是说没有什么好看的，就像它很无聊一样。我的意思是真的什么都没有。电视网只在晚上 7 点之后播出节目。但随后，在 1947 年，NBC 从杂耍剧本中借用了另一招，即木偶戏，从而找到了新的节目播放内容。
Puppets were highly visual, they were live, they were cheap, and perhaps most importantly, kids loved them. The plan was to do a one-hour kids' special at the ungodly early hour of 5 p.m. They called it Puppet Playhouse, and they tapped Bob Smith to host it, along with his country yokel sidekick, Howdy Doody. And it is important to remember it didn't have any competition to speak of, because it was kind of the first network kids show.
木偶戏具有极强的视觉效果，它们是现场直播的，成本低廉，而且也许最重要的是，孩子们非常喜欢它们。计划在傍晚 5 点这个非同寻常的早时间段制作一个一小时的儿童特辑。他们称之为《木偶剧场》，并邀请鲍勃·史密斯担任主持，还有他的乡村乡巴佬搭档豪迪·杜迪。值得记住的是，它没有任何值得一提的竞争对手，因为它是同类中第一个电视网儿童节目。
And just like Milton Berle, it was going to be a vaudeville show made for television. Howdy Doody, which premiered around the same time on the same network, NBC, was essentially the Milton Burrell show for kids. The show was scheduled to air on December 27th, but they didn't greenlight it until the week before Christmas. So the producers only had two weeks to put together a live program. Bob Smith said that he didn't
就像弥尔顿·伯le 的节目一样，这将是一个为电视制作的杂耍秀。《豪迪·杜迪》大约在同一时间在同一电视网 NBC 首播，本质上就是儿童版的《弥尔顿·伯le秀》。该节目原定于 12 月 27 日播出，但直到圣诞节前一周才获批。因此，制作人只有两周的时间来拼凑一个直播节目。鲍勃·史密斯说他直到
find out he was hosting the show until four days before the broadcast date. And the stakes were very high for Bob Smith's television debut. He was about to have an unexpectedly huge audience. The day before Puppet Playhouse went on the air, it started snowing in New York, and it didn't stop for 24 hours. A record-breaking storm dumped mountains of snow on New York City. So, um, the day after the big snowstorm was the airing of the very first live public playoff show. This is Chance Mitchell.
播出日期前四天才知道自己要主持这个节目。鲍勃·史密斯的电视首秀面临着巨大的风险。他将迎来一个意想不到的庞大观众群。《木偶剧场》开播的前一天，纽约开始下雪，而且连续 24 小时没有停。一场破纪录的风暴给纽约市倾泻了成吨的雪。所以，嗯，大风暴过后的那一天，就是第一场现场公众剧场秀的播出。这是钱斯·米切尔。
He runs the Duttyville Historical Society. Basically, the Howdy Doody fan club. Luckily, Bob had already been in the studio for a while. So when everybody was snowed in, they were kind of snowed in too. Chance says that the snowstorm closed down all the typical entertainment options. There were no shows on Broadway, no music in the clubs, all the movie theaters shuttered. Everyone was stuck at home. And there were only three TV stations at the time.
他负责杜迪维尔历史协会。基本上就是豪迪·杜迪粉丝俱乐部。幸运的是，鲍勃已经在演播室待了一段时间。所以当所有人都被大雪困住时，他们其实也被困在了里面。钱斯说，暴风雪关闭了所有典型的娱乐选择。百老汇没有演出，夜总会没有音乐，所有的电影院都关门了。每个人都被困在家里的。当时只有三个电视台。
Two of the stations were showing basketball games that night. The third was debuting Puppet Playhouse. So everybody was at home, so everybody tuned into this puppet show that was on the air. The only problem was there was no puppet. Remember, they'd only had two weeks to adapt material that had been designed for the radio into highly visual entertainment, including designing a physical Howdy Doody, because up until then, he had just been a voice. And the puppeteer didn't have enough time to finish the puppet before the show went live. So they improvised. When the moment came for Howdy to
其中两个台当晚在转播篮球比赛。第三个台则在首播《木偶剧场》。所以每个人都在家，于是每个人都收看了这个正在播出的木偶秀。唯一的毛病是没有木偶。记住，他们只有两周时间将为广播设计的素材改编为高度视觉化的娱乐内容，包括设计一个实体版的豪迪·杜迪，因为在此之前，他只是一个声音。木偶师没有足够的时间在节目直播前完成木偶制作。于是他们即兴发挥。当豪迪登场的
make his entrance, Buffalo Bob told the small handful of kids that had made it to the studio that sadly poor old Howdy was too shy to appear in front of the camera. So he was hiding in Bob's desk drawer. And he would go over to the desk drawer and say, are you in there Howdy? And Howdy would say, oh yeah, but I'm too bashful to come out. Well, he was too bashful for three weeks. And in spite of the fact that no one could see the start of the show,
时刻到来时，水牛比勃告诉来到演播室的少数几个孩子，可怜的老豪迪太害羞了，不敢在镜头前露面。所以他躲在比勃的抽屉里。他会走到抽屉旁说：“你在里面吗，豪迪？”豪迪会说：“哦，是的，但我太害羞了，不敢出来。”好吧，他害羞了整整三周。尽管没有人能看到节目的明星，
or who knows, maybe because they couldn't see him, the kids loved it. NBC decided to give Bob Smith his own children's TV show five nights a week. And mothers would take their kids, plop them in front of the television set, Howdy Doody would come on, and they could do something else. So it was the first show in television history, really, to see TV as a babysitter. Suddenly, a new beautiful gift was given to parents
或者谁知道呢，也许正是因为他们看不到他，孩子们却非常喜欢。NBC 决定让鲍勃·史密斯每周有五天拥有自己的儿童电视节目。母亲们会带着孩子，把他们塞到电视机前，《豪迪·杜迪》就会开播，然后她们就可以去忙别的了。所以它确实是电视史上第一个把电视视为保姆的节目。突然间，父母们收到了一份美丽的新礼物，
all around the country, a break beautiful gift was given to parents all around the country. A break from their little monsters. Every episode of this new show opened with a question. Hey kids, what time is it? It's time to eat! It's time to eat! It's time to eat! And there was a live studio audience.
全国各地的父母都收到了礼物，可以从他们的小怪物身边解放片刻。这个新节目的每一集都是以一个问题开场的。嘿，孩子们，现在几点了？该吃饭了！该吃饭了！该吃饭了！现场有演播室观众。
They all sat together and they were called the Peanut Gallery. And if you watch any of the old shows, the boys and girls are still very dressed up. The kids would all be wearing coats and ties and party dresses. And there, less than 10 feet away on the stage, was Bob, along with Howdy, who did eventually come out from that desk drawer. Howdy, Doody, how did you like hearing that, little fella? Well, Mr. Smith, that was, oh, it was just wonderful. It's so thrilling when the boys and girls sing my song so loud.
他们都坐在一起，被称为“花生画廊”。如果你看任何老节目，男孩和女孩们仍然穿得非常正式。孩子们都穿着外套、系着领带、穿着派对礼服。就在不到 10 英尺远的舞台上，鲍勃和豪迪都在那里，豪迪最终确实从那个办公桌抽屉里出来了。“豪迪，杜迪，听到这个你觉得怎么样，小家伙？”“嗯，史密斯先生，那是，哦，太棒了。少男少女们大声唱我的歌，真是太令人激动了。”
Now I just want to pause right here and say that if you have any familiarity with Howdy Doody, you probably have an image in your mind of what this puppet looks like. But the Howdy that is currently prancing around in your brain is not the Howdy Doody that first appeared on the show. The original Howdy Doody was a different puppet, one that a lot of people thought was hideously ugly. And allegedly it was too scary for the kids. I don't really believe that to be the case, but that's the story that Bob and people around
现在我想在这里停顿一下，如果你对豪迪·杜迪有所了解，你的脑海里可能有一个这个木偶长相的画面。但现在在你脑海里蹦蹦跳跳的那个豪迪，并不是最初在节目中出现的那个豪迪·杜迪。最初的豪迪·杜迪是一个不同的木偶，许多人认为它丑得骇人。据说它把孩子们吓坏了。我其实不相信是这样，但这就是鲍勃和鲍勃身边的人
Bob would say about the puppet. They eventually ended up calling him Ugly Duty. He kind of looked like Beaker from The Muppets, in my opinion. But it didn't matter. In spite of him being ugly, or who knows, perhaps because he was so ugly, the kids loved Howdy. Even more than when he was stuck in the drawer. Though it's possible they would have loved a mop with googly eyes. This was, after all, the first time that kids watched television.
关于这个木偶的故事。他们最终管他叫丑陋杜迪。依我看，他看起来有点像《布偶秀》里的比克。但这没关系。尽管他很丑，或者谁知道呢，也许正是因为他太丑了，孩子们还是非常喜欢豪迪。甚至比他被困在抽屉里时还要喜欢。尽管他们可能也会喜欢一个长着大眼睛的拖把。毕竟，这是孩子们第一次看电视。
But it's also the case that Howdy was just...nice. He's always a positive, outgoing, happy 10-year-old. He was 10 in 1947 and 75 years later he's still 10. Everything that Howdy does is for the good of the whole community of Duttyville, not just for himself. Howdy was operated by a woman named Rhoda Mayan. She stood on a platform above the set, holding Howdy's strings. She was an especially gifted puppeteer who excelled at making Howdy move as much as possible
但事实也是，豪迪非常……善良。他一直是一个积极、外向、快乐的 10 岁男孩。他在 1947 年是 10 岁，75 年后他依然是 10 岁。豪迪所做的一切都是为了杜迪维尔整个社区的利益，而不仅仅是为了他自己。豪迪由一个名叫罗达·玛雅的女性操控。她站在布景上方的一个平台上，拉着豪迪的绳子。她是一位极有天赋的木偶师，擅长让豪迪尽可能像
like a real human. And Bob and Howdy would have all sorts of adventures together, usually designed to teach the kids a valuable lesson. And it's actually a magic word, friendship. I hope all the kids know what friendship really is, Mr. Smith. Although since his previous voice acting had been for the radio, Bob Smith never learned to throw his voice. So anytime Howdy talked, Bob had to be off screen. Well, I think they do. Matter of fact, I could go over and find out about it.
真人一样移动。鲍勃和豪迪会一起经历各种各样的冒险，通常旨在教给孩子们宝贵的课程。这其实是一个神奇的词，友谊。我希望所有的孩子都知道什么是真正的友谊，史密斯先生。虽然他以前的配音工作是为广播服务的，但鲍勃·史密斯从未学会腹语。所以每当豪迪说话时，鲍勃都必须在镜头外。嗯，我想他们会的。事实上，我可以过去了解一下。
Do you all have a lot of friends, I hope? Yes! fact I could go over and find out about it. Do you all have a lot of friends I hope? Yeah! Well now what do you think are some of the best ways that you could possibly make a friend? There was also a rotating cast of other characters including live actors like a mute clown named Clarabel who kept blasting everyone in the face with a horn and a seltzer bottle, just like Milton Berle's old act. Which apparently caused the same maniacal laughter in kids that it did in adults. This being a 1950s show about cowboys, there were also some Native American characters that traded on racist stereotypes. They were played by white actors, including an Indian princess and an Indian chief named Thunder Thud, who is mainly remembered for coining the term cowabunga.
希望你们都有很多朋友吧？是的！事实上我可以过去了解一下。希望你们都有很多朋友吧？是的！那么现在，你认为结交朋友最好的方法有哪些？节目中还有一个不断轮换的其他角色阵容，包括真人演员，比如一个名叫克拉贝尔的哑剧小丑，他不断用喇叭和苏打水瓶朝每个人的脸喷射，就像弥尔顿·伯le的老表演一样。这显然引起了孩子们和成年人一样狂热的笑声。作为一个关于牛仔的 20 世纪 50 年代节目，其中也有一些利用种族刻板印象的美洲原住民角色。他们由白人演员扮演，包括一位印第安公主和一位名叫雷霆重击（Thunder Thud）的印第安酋长，他主要因为创造了“考阿邦加”（cowabunga）一词而被人们记住。
But mainly there were puppets. Wonderful, inventive, gloriously cost-saving puppets, including the Flubber Dove, a creature that was eight animals in one, and Phineas T. Bluster, the villainous mayor of Duttyville. Here's Bert Dubrow again, our 10-year-old Howdy Doody superfan. He says Mayor Bluster often had some scheme he was cooking up. There was an Easter egg episode
但主要还是木偶。精彩、富有创意、极其节省成本的木偶，包括“福禄伯·多夫”（Flubber Dove），这是一种八合一动物的生物，还有菲尼亚斯·T·布鲁斯特（Phineas T. Bluster），杜迪维尔邪恶的市长。这是伯特·杜布罗，我们 10 岁的豪迪·杜迪超级粉丝。他说布鲁斯特市长经常在酝酿一些阴谋。有一个复活节彩蛋剧集，
where Mr. Bluster bought all the Easter eggs in Duttyville, all of them, so that they would have them buy them from him and he would overcharge them. So just to piss off everybody and upset the kids. You get the point I'm making here? Yes. Okay. The executives at NBC knew they had a quality television show on their hands.
布鲁斯特先生买下了杜迪维尔所有的复活节彩蛋，所有的彩蛋，这样他们就不得不向他买，而他会索要高价。所以这只是为了惹恼所有人并让孩子们心烦意乱。你明白我的意思了吗？是的。好的。NBC 的高管们知道他们手头有一个优质的电视节目。
But the problem was, there was no easy way of knowing just how many kids were actually watching it. Nielsen television ratings didn't exist yet, making it hard to sell the program to sponsors. Not without data. And without sponsors, there was no profit. So in 1948, the suits at NBC and the writers at Howdy Doody devised a scheme worthy of Phineas T. Bluster himself. Eddie Keene, the absolute genius script writer and songwriter for the show, came up with
但问题是，没有简单的方法知道到底有多少孩子在看。尼尔森收视率当时还不存在，这使得向赞助商推销节目变得困难。没有数据，就无法推销。没有赞助商，就没有利润。因此，在 1948 年，NBC 的高管和《豪迪·杜迪》的编剧们策划了一个配得上菲尼亚斯·T·布鲁斯特本人的阴谋。埃迪·基恩（Eddie Keene），该节目绝对是个天才的剧作家和词曲作者，想出了
the idea that Howdy decided he would run for president of all the kids in the United States. Howdy told the kids watching at home that if they mailed in a postcard with a write-in vote for Howdy to the NBC office, he would send them their very own Howdy Doody campaign button. Now kids, I want you to all make sure of this. Now this is the last chance that you have to vote. Just the end of this week and all the votes must be in. The more postcards that came in asking for buttons, the more kids must be watching the
一个主意：豪迪决定竞选全美所有儿童的总统。豪迪告诉电视机前的孩子们，如果他们寄出一张写有投票给豪迪的明信片到 NBC 办公室，他就会寄给他们他们专属的豪迪·杜迪竞选徽章。现在孩子们，我希望你们所有人都确保这一点。现在这是你们投票的最后机会。就在本周末结束前，所有选票必须全部寄到。寄来索要徽章的明信片越多，说明看节目的孩子就越多。
show. And that in turn would help NBC sell the program to potential sponsors. "...and then it's box 333, box 333, and then it's New York 19 New York. Now come on, all of you kids get in there and vote, will ya? And so they thought, you know, maybe we can print up, you know, probably 5,000 buttons or something. Well, at the end of the entire run, they had reached a total of 60,000 buttons. This was an insane number. We don't actually know how many postcards would have come in, because NBC's mailroom got so overwhelmed they refused to accept any more. By which point the number of postcards received was equal to one third
这反过来又会帮助 NBC 将节目卖给潜在赞助商。“……然后是 333 号信箱，333 号信箱，然后是纽约 19 纽约。现在来吧，所有的孩子们都去投票吧，好吗？”他们想，你知道的，也许我们可以印制，你知道的，大概 5000 个徽章什么的。嗯，在整个活动结束时，他们总共发放了 60,000 个徽章。这是一个疯狂的数字。我们其实不知道到底收到了多少明信片，因为 NBC 的收发室不堪重负，拒绝再接收任何邮件。此时收到的明信片数量等于全美电视机总数的
the total number of TV sets in America. That was more households than were technically able to get Howdy Doody. Which proved that kids and their families would go over to their neighbor's house that did have a television set and sit down and watch the Howdy Ditty show. And so this got them sold out completely. Within months, some of the biggest brands in the country wanted to sponsor the show. Colgate, Ovaltine, Kellogg's. The department store Macy's wanted to sell Howdy dolls.
三分之一。这比当时技术上能够接收到《豪迪·杜迪》节目的家庭还要多。这证明了孩子们和他们的家人会去他们拥有电视机的邻居家串门，坐下来观看《豪迪·杜迪秀》。因此，这让他们彻底卖断货了。几个月内，国内一些最大的品牌都想赞助该节目。高露洁、阿华田、家乐氏。百货公司梅西百货想要销售豪迪玩偶。
And NBC was more than happy to arrange a licensing deal. Money was pouring in. But there was one person who was not getting a cent, Frank Parris, the man who had designed the howdy duty puppet. NBC had only paid him $500 to make it, but Buffalo Bob and NBC owned all the rights to the character. Well, Frank got very angry at this and one day barged into the office and said,
NBC 非常乐意安排授权交易。资金源源不断地涌入。但有一个人一分钱也没得到，弗兰克·帕里斯（Frank Parris），那个设计了豪迪·杜迪木偶的人。NBC 只付给他 500 美元来制作它，但水牛比勃和 NBC 拥有该角色的所有权利。嗯，弗兰克对此非常生气，有一天闯进办公室说：
well, if you think it's your puppet, see how you do a show tonight. Took the puppet and went home around two o'clock in the afternoon when the show had to be on at five. Howdy Doody was supposed to go live in a matter of hours and the star of the show was missing. Again, puppet-napped by its disgruntled creator. And because the show's producers were still learning how to run a television show, they had only made the one puppet. There were no backups.
好吧，如果你觉得这是你的木偶，看看你今晚怎么做节目。下午两点左右，在节目必须在五点播出的时候，他拿着木偶回家了。豪迪·杜迪本应在几个小时内进行直播，但节目的明星却失踪了。再次被他心怀不满的创造者“绑架”了。由于节目的制作人仍在学习如何运营电视节目，他们只制作了一个木偶。没有任何备份。
They would need time to make a new one, leaving Buffalo Bob and the writers to come up with one of the most preposterous storylines in the history of television. Because when Frank Parris stormed out with Howdy Doody, aka Ugly Doody, they realized that it might just provide the perfect excuse to give Howdy the visual upgrade they had always wanted. After the opening theme song, Buffalo Bob explained to the kids in the peanut gallery that Howdy would not be joining them today because he was out campaigning to be president
他们需要时间制作一个新的，这让水牛比勃和编剧们不得不构思电视史上最荒谬的故事情节之一。因为当弗兰克·帕里斯带着豪迪·杜迪（又名丑陋杜迪）怒气冲冲地离开时，他们意识到这可能正好提供了一个完美的借口，给豪迪进行他们一直想要的视觉升级。开场主题曲播放完后，水牛比勃向花生画廊的孩子们解释说，豪迪今天不能加入他们了，因为他在外地竞选总统，
and while he was on the campaign trail, Howdy had met his opponent, a mysterious man who went by the name Mr. X. And Eddie Keene came up with the idea, which sounds so ridiculous now, that he ran into his running mate, Mr. X, and Mr. X was very handsome and getting all the votes from all the girls. Buffalo Bob told the kids that after Howdy met his insanely handsome opponent, he had come to the sad realization
在竞选之路上，豪迪遇到了他的对手，一个自称 X 先生的神秘男子。埃迪·基恩想出了一个现在听起来非常荒谬的主意，那就是他遇到了他的竞争对手 X 先生，X 先生非常英俊，赢得了所有女孩的选票。水牛比勃告诉孩子们，在豪迪遇到了他那个英俊得令人发指的对手后，他悲哀地意识到
that he was too ugly to be president. But fear not, because there was a solution. Howdy was going to visit a plastic surgeon. For a few weeks after that, from the neck down, Howdy looked just like his old self. But from the neck up, he had bandages covering his head. That way, none of the kids realize that it was
自己太丑了，不适合当总统。但不用担心，因为有解决办法。豪迪要去拜访一位整形外科医生。在那之后的几个星期里，从脖子以下看，豪迪看起来和以前一样。但从脖子以上看，他的头上缠着绷带。这样，孩子们就不会意识到这
just some random puppet standing in for the star. In the meantime, they fire Frank, they get rid of the ugly puppet, and now they got to find someone to make a new one, a good looking one. NBC hired a woman named Velma Dawson to create a new Howdy Doody puppet, one that would not allegedly frighten small children. And on June 8, 1948, the new Howdy was ready. And so then when the new one came in, they took that puppet, put bandages around him,
只是某个随机的木偶在代替明星站台。与此同时，他们解雇了弗兰克，除掉了丑陋的木偶，现在他们必须找人制作一个新的，一个好看的新木偶。NBC 雇佣了一位名叫维尔玛·道森（Velma Dawson）的女性来创建一个新的豪迪·杜迪木偶，一个据称不会吓到小孩子的木偶。1948 年 6 月 8 日，新的豪迪准备就绪。于是当新木偶到来时，他们拿过那个木偶，在它周围缠上绷带，
and then they unveiled him. Slowly, Buffalo Bob unwrapped Howdy's bandaged head, and a freckled, bulbous-cheeked child gazed out at the world with its unblinking blue eyes and a perpetually smiling face. The surgery was a success. The future president of the kids of the United States had arrived, and the kids went wild. For the next decade, Howdy Doody had an unprecedented run of success. It was the first kids show to be broadcast nationally
然后将其揭幕。水牛比勃慢慢地拆开豪迪缠着绷带的头，一个长着雀斑、双颊饱满的孩子用它眨也不眨的蓝眼睛和一张永远微笑着的脸凝视着世界。手术很成功。美国儿童未来的总统已经到来，孩子们疯狂了。在接下来的十年里，《豪迪·杜迪》取得了空前的成功。它是第一个在全国范围内播出的儿童节目，
and the first to regularly broadcast in color. And as the show became more popular, so too did television itself. When Howdy Doody first went on the air in December of 1947, there were fewer than 200,000 television sets in America. By 1960, it was the longest running show on TV, and America had nearly 50 million televisions. Almost 90% of the country owned a TV.
也是第一个定期进行彩色广播的节目。随着节目越来越受欢迎，电视本身也越来越受欢迎。1947 年 12 月《豪迪·杜迪》首次开播时，美国全境的电视机还不到 20 万台。到 1960 年，它已经是电视上播出时间最长的节目，美国拥有近 5000 万台电视机。全国近 90% 的家庭都拥有电视。
This freckled 10-year-old boy embedded himself into the minds of an entire generation of children in the 1950s. And the thing that Howdy fans dreamed of more than anything was to be one of those lucky few kids who got to experience the show in person as a member of the Peanut Gallery gallery to feel that fine mist of seltzer on their face as it rained down from Claribel's bottle. I do remember like it was yesterday walking into that studio. Superfan Bert Dubrow says that back when he was a kid after he finally won Bob
这个满脸雀斑的 10 岁男孩深深烙印在 20 世纪 50 年代整整一代孩子的脑海中。豪迪迷们最大的梦想，莫过于成为那少数几个幸运儿之一，能够作为“花生画廊”的一员亲自体验这个节目，感受到克拉贝尔瓶子里喷出的细密苏打水雾像雨点般落在他们的脸上。我还记得就像昨天一样，走进那个演播室。超级粉丝伯特·杜布罗说，当他还是个孩子的时候，在他最终赢得鲍勃的信任之后，
over, Bob gave him a handful of tickets to a taping of the show and even though he had seen Bob behind the counter of the liquor store dozens of times by then, when he stepped into the studio, he was transported. Up to that point, Burt had only ever experienced Howdy Doody on his black and white television. And only I can compare it to is in The Wizard of Oz, you know, it starts out in black and white, and then when they open the door and she's in Oz, you see the color, that's what this was like for me. And there's everything. I mean, there's the puppets and the, I mean everything that I knew.
鲍勃给了他几张录制节目的门票，尽管当时他已经在酒馆柜台后面看过鲍勃几十次了，但当他踏入演播室的那一刻，他被震撼了。在此之前，伯特只在黑白电视机上体验过《豪迪·杜迪》。我唯一能想到的就是《绿野仙踪》，你知道的，它一开始是黑白的，然后当他们打开门，她到了奥兹国，你看到了彩色，我当时的感受就是这样。而且应有尽有。我是说，有木偶和，我是说我所知道的一切。
Better than anybody knew it. Then all of a sudden Bob, or I should say Buffalo Bob now, came through the cameras and yelled out, where's Bert? And my friends were on the Peanut gallery and they can't believe it. And he said, they introduced me to your friends and it was ridiculous. When we come back, the story of how the medium that Howdy Doody helped create would pass
比任何人都清楚。然后突然间鲍勃，或者我现在应该叫水牛比勃，从镜头后走过来大喊：“伯特在哪里？”我的朋友们都在花生画廊上，他们简直不敢相信。他说，他们把我介绍给你的朋友们，这太荒谬了。当我们回来时，我们将讲述豪迪·杜迪帮助创造的媒介如何抛弃了鲍勃和豪迪，并且再也没有回头的故事。当我们离开时，《豪迪·杜迪》似乎正处于其受欢迎程度、威望和盈利能力的巅峰。当时，无论是孩子还是成年人，都很难想象这个节目会结束。但是，对于像年轻的伯特·杜布罗这样的粉丝来说，坐在花生画廊里是多么不可思议。
Bob and Howdy by and never look back after this. When we left, the Howdy Doody show appeared to be at the height of its popularity, its prestige and its profitability. At the time, it would have been hard for kids and adults alike to imagine the show ever ending. But incredible as it was for fans like the young Burt Dubrow to sit in the peanut gallery. The truth was that for a long time, just behind the scenes, the Howdy Doody show had been having problems. One of which was money.
事实是，很长一段时间以来，就在幕后，《豪迪·杜迪》一直存在问题。其中之一就是钱。
In 1950, Buffalo Bob agreed to sell Howdy Doody to a new company created by NBC and the Wall Street firm Lehman Brothers. The name of this new company was Kagran, which in my humble opinion sounds like the name a TV writer would come up with for a soulless corporation that buys a beloved children's television show with the singular focus on squeezing as much money from the pockets of children's parents as possible. Which coincidentally is exactly what happened. When Cagrin took over, sponsors became increasingly involved
1950 年，水牛比勃同意将《豪迪·杜迪》卖给由 NBC 和华尔街雷曼兄弟公司成立的新公司。这家新公司的名字叫卡格兰（Kagran），在我看来，这个名字听起来就像一个电视编剧会为一个冷酷无情的公司想出来的名字，这家公司收购了一个深受喜爱的儿童电视节目，唯一的焦点就是尽可能多地榨取孩子们父母口袋里的钱。这巧合地正是所发生的事情。当卡格兰接管后，赞助商越来越深地介入其中，
both onscreen and off. More and more companies started to see the potential of marketing their products to kids, or through kids. As Buffalo Bob told children to get their parents to buy this or that product, Howdy became a marketing bonanza. Kids, look here. Clarabel has this whole lunchbox just filled with Hostess Twinkies.
无论是在屏幕上还是屏幕外。越来越多的公司开始看到向儿童或通过儿童营销产品的潜力。正如水牛比勃告诉孩子们让他们的父母买这个或那个产品一样，豪迪成了一个营销金矿。孩子们，看这里。克拉贝尔的整个午餐盒里都装满了好时甜甜圈（Hostess Twinkies）。
So kids, you ask mom to buy some Hostess Twinkies the next time she goes to the store. Howdy's face began staring at people from bread packaging and juice bottles. And eventually, there was a backlash to the show. It provided an early window into how television would be criticized by intellectuals. And they could make the argument that how can you show this crud to children? It's going to have this terrible effect on them. Leaving out for a second that Milton Berle was the same show so adults were consuming the crud just as much as the children were.
所以孩子们，下次妈妈去商店时，你们要求她买一些好时甜甜圈。豪迪的脸开始从面包包装和果汁瓶上注视着人们。最终，该节目遭到了强烈反对。它为了解知识分子如何批评电视提供了一个早期窗口。他们可以提出这样的论据：你怎么能向孩子们展示这种垃圾？它会对他们产生如此可怕的影响。暂时抛开弥尔顿·伯le的节目也是一样，成年人和儿童一样都在消费这些垃圾不谈。
At the same time TV was evolving as a medium. New children shows were popping up. Howdy had competition including perhaps the biggest development in children's television, the cartoon. Here I come to save the day. That means that mighty mouth. The other networks realized that airing cartoons was cheaper than filming a bunch of actors on a soundstage every week, and kids loved them.
与此同时，电视作为一种媒介正在不断演变。新的儿童节目如雨后春笋般涌现。豪迪面临着竞争，其中包括可能是儿童电视领域最伟大的发展——动画片。我来拯救世界了。这意味着大力鼠。其他网络意识到，播放动画片比每周在摄影棚里拍摄一群演员更便宜，而且孩子们非常喜欢它们。
And of course, puppets, compared to a cartoon character, they can't possibly compete because they fit the style of the medium. And the competing live action shows didn't go away. They just got more visually sophisticated, including the show that perhaps would prove to be the perfect marriage of live action and cartoon IP. Who's the leader of the front that's made for you and me? N.Y.C. J.G. Watt, N.O.U.S.C. Mickey Mouse, ha ha ha! Mickey Mouse, ha ha ha!
当然，与动画角色相比，木偶根本无法竞争，因为它们适应了这种媒介的风格。而且竞争的真人秀节目并没有消失。它们只是在视觉上变得更加复杂，包括那个可能被证明是真人秀和动画 IP 完美结合的节目。谁是前线的领袖，为你我而生？米老鼠，哈哈哈哈！米老鼠，哈哈哈哈！
The Mickey Mouse Club featured a cast of singing and dancing kids alongside serials often involving Disney characters. Meanwhile, Howdy Doody, the show that never met a problem it couldn't innovate its way out of, had stopped innovating. It was just the same old vaudeville puppet show. As programs like the Mickey Mouse Club evolved around it, Howdy looked increasingly old-fashioned and threadbare. So, by 1960, when it left the air, I mean basically the air had left them,
《米老鼠俱乐部》由一群唱歌跳舞的孩子以及通常涉及迪士尼角色的系列片组成。与此同时，《豪迪·杜迪》，这个从未遇到过无法通过创新解决的问题的节目，却停止了创新。它只是老一套的杂耍木偶秀。随着像《米老鼠俱乐部》这样的节目在其周围不断演变，豪迪显得越来越过时和破旧。所以，到 1960 年它停播时，我的意思是基本上时代已经抛弃了它们，
because the other shows were better. In 1956, the executives at NBC cut the show back from five days a week to just one on Saturday afternoon. Suddenly, everyone on the show was only making a fraction of the money they had before. Bert says that's one of the reasons Bob purchased the liquor store. It was his way of giving some of the money they had before. Burt says that's one of the reasons Bob purchased the liquor store. It was his way of giving some of the show's staff a job.
因为其他的节目更优秀。1956 年，NBC 的高管将该节目从每周五天缩减为每周六下午一天。突然之间，节目中的每个人赚到的钱都只是以前的一小部分。伯特说这就是鲍勃买下酒馆的原因之一。这是他为节目的一些员工提供工作的一种方式。伯特说，这就是鲍勃买下酒馆的原因之一。这是他为节目的一些员工提供工作的一种方式。
He wanted something for the guys at work for him to do after the show was off the air. He knew the show was going to go away. The last episode of Howdy Doody aired in 1960. Bob Smith had not planned on being just a children's entertainer, but he didn't have a second act after he hung up his Buffalo Bob outfit. And it was during this Twilight period that our intrepid superfan, Burt Dubrow, actually becomes part of the story. When he grew up, he went to college in Boston, but he never stopped being fascinated with
他想让那些为他工作的小伙子们在节目停播后有点事可做。他知道这个节目会消失。《豪迪·杜迪》的最后一集于 1960 年播出。鲍勃·史密斯本来没打算只做一个儿童艺人，但在他挂掉水牛比勃的行头后，他并没有第二春。正是在这段暮年时期，我们的无畏超级粉丝伯特·杜布罗真正成为了故事的一部分。长大后，他在波士顿上大学，但他对娱乐行业的迷恋从未停止。
the entertainment industry. What was the dream at that point? What did you want? Just to be in television. To be a producer, to be in television. I'm not even sure producer just to be in it, but it was because it was live and it was real. So once it became cartoons, I didn't have an interest in it anymore, but I always did with talk, always, always. Then in 1970, he heard that Buffalo Bob was coming to town to perform. He had been doing a Howdy Doody revival tour.
当时的梦想是什么？你想要什么？只是为了进电视圈。成为一名制作人，进入电视行业。我甚至不确定是不是制作人，只是想身处其中，但那是因为它是现场直播的，而且它是真实的。所以一旦它变成了动画片，我就对它不感兴趣了，但我对访谈节目一直很感兴趣，一直是。然后在 1970 年，他听说水牛比勃要来镇上演出。他一直在进行《豪迪·杜迪》复兴巡演。
So I go to the auditorium, I sit down, big place, probably 1,500 people, and it's like there's Buffalo Bob. And in spite of the fact that Bob was effectively putting on a show designed for toddlers in front of a bunch of grown men, or who knows, perhaps because he was putting on a show for toddlers in front of a bunch of grown men, the audience loved it. And he was putting on a show for toddlers in front of a bunch of grown men, the audience loved it. And he was effing amazing.
所以我去了礼堂，坐了下来，地方很大，大概有1500人，就像布法罗·鲍勃在那儿一样。尽管鲍勃实际上是在一群成年人面前为幼儿表演节目，或者谁知道呢，也许正是因为他在一群成年人面前为幼儿表演节目，观众们非常喜欢它。而且他在一群成年人面前为幼儿表演节目，观众们非常喜欢它。而且他简直太棒了。
All the songs, sang all the songs, did everything, everybody knew the words to every song. Like an idiot, I'm singing the songs too. And when the show was over, Burt went to see Bob and his brother Vic backstage. He knew that Bob had had a heart attack several years earlier. And he figured that Bob's health was as good a reason as any
所有的歌都唱了，把所有的歌都唱了，什么都做了，每个人都会唱每首歌的词。像个傻瓜一样，我也在唱歌。演出结束后，伯特去后台看望了鲍勃和他的兄弟维克。他知道鲍勃几年前心脏病发作过。他觉得鲍勃的健康状况是一个再好不过的理由
to get his foot into the door of show business. So I said to Vic, listen, he needs me on the road. He'll drop dead. He's gonna get another heart attack. Anyway, Bob called me and said, let's do it. You'll travel with me and all that. And it was rough. He was rough. He was not
来踏入演艺圈。所以我对维克说，听着，他路上需要我。他会死的。他会再次心脏病发作。不管怎样，鲍勃打电话给我说，我们干吧。你跟我一起旅行诸如此类的。这很艰难。他很艰难。他不是
easy. What do you mean? He was very demanding and I'd say Moody, I didn't get my own room on the road, so I didn't sleep in the same room as Hamlet. So I think I got $25 or $50 a show. That was it. But I couldn't have been happier. Burt's decision to drop out of college and pursue a career in television paid off. He went on to create the Sally Jesse Raphael Show. And then after it became a hit, he came across a local news anchor in Cincinnati and he thought this guy should have his own talk show.
很容易。你什么意思？他要求很高，而且我觉得他喜怒无常，我在路上没有自己的房间，所以我和哈姆雷特没有睡在同一个房间。所以我想我每场演出能拿到25美元或50美元。就是这样。但我不可能更开心了。伯特辍学并追求电视事业的决定得到了回报。他后来制作了《莎莉·杰西·拉斐尔秀》。在它大获成功之后，他在辛辛那提遇到了一位当地的新闻主播，他认为这个人应该有自己的脱口秀节目。
That anchor's name was Jerry Springer. Jerry! Jerry! Jerry! Jerry! It started out as a straight show and ended up with throwing chairs. But... I interviewed Burt at his home in Denver, Colorado. He told me we would be doing the interview in his basement. And I was not prepared for what was down there. Get ready. Go ahead, I'll meet you down there.
那个主播的名字叫杰瑞·斯普林格。杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！它最初是一个正统的节目，最后以扔椅子告终。但是……我在科罗拉多州丹佛市的家中采访了伯特。他告诉我我们将在他的地下室进行采访。我对外面的地下室里有什么毫无准备。准备好。走吧，我在下面等你。
Okay, alright, sounds good. When we descended the stairs, I was greeted by the smiling faces of so many puppets. It was like a museum. Let me put the lights on. Wow, this is amazing. Yeah, feel free to look around. Yeah, I'd love you to give me a little tour and try to... Sure, sure, sure.
好的，好吧，听起来不错。当我们走下楼梯时，迎接我的是许多木偶的笑脸。这就像一个博物馆。让我把灯打开。哇，太棒了。是的，随便看看吧。是的，我很想让你带我参观一下，并试着……当然，当然，当然。
There's a buffalo bod suit. Oh, wow. And there's Clarabelle's. That's the real stuff. Oh, yeah. That's the... This is the last seltzer bottle he used. The last one.
那里有一套布法罗·鲍勃的服装。哦，哇。还有克拉贝儿的。那是真货。哦，是的。那是……这是他用过的最后一个苏打水瓶。最后一个。
All around me, everywhere I looked, was something from the original Howdy Doody show. All the costumes and props and photographs and puppets. I felt kind of like how Bert must have felt when he first went to that taping and finally got to see everything in color. That's the original Princess Summerform Winter Spring puppet.
我周围，无论我看到哪里，都有来自原版《豪迪·杜迪》节目的东西。所有的服装、道具、照片和木偶。我感觉有点像伯特第一次去那个录制现场并最终看到所有东西都是彩色时的感受。那是原版的萨默弗姆·温特·斯普林公主木偶。
One of the hats they used to give away at the peanut gallery. There I am in the peanut gallery that day. That's me. Right there, yeah. When I asked Bert how he got all this stuff, he says that when the revival tour was winding down, he asked Bob if he could keep a few things. And Bob couldn't understand why he would want any of it.
他们过去常在花生画廊赠送的帽子之一。那一天我在花生画廊里。那是我。就在那里，是的。当我问伯特他是如何弄到所有这些东西时，他说当巡回演出接近尾声时，他问鲍勃他是否可以留几件东西。而鲍勃不明白他为什么会想要这些。
This was before collectibles really took off. So when the show wrapped, he gave Burt everything that happened to be left. And so here I am sitting with, you know, Claribel's box and the horns and hold on here, hold on. Everybody will recognize that, that knows how to do, will recognize that. And that's the actual horn. It's one of them. There's Bob and Springer in me. Burt led me around his basement,
这发生在收藏品真正流行起来之前。所以节目结束时碰巧剩下什么，他把所有的东西都给了伯特。所以现在我坐在这里，你知道的，有克拉贝儿的盒子、号角，等等，等等。每个人都会认出这个，知道怎么做的人，会认出这个。这就是那个真正的号角。它是其中之一。那是鲍勃、斯普林格和我。伯特带我参观了他的地下室，
glass of ice water in his hand, pointing out various pieces of memorabilia from his long career in show business. And there, in a corner, standing upright was the star of the show, Howdy Doody himself. One of the very few puppets made from the original mold that was used of the show, Howdy Doody himself. One of the very few puppets made from the original mold that was used on the show when Howdy first came out of plastic surgery.
手里拿着一杯冰水，指着他在演艺生涯中获得的各种纪念品。就在一个角落里，站着节目的主角——豪迪·杜迪本人。这是用节目中豪迪刚做完整形手术时所使用的原版模具制作的极少数木偶之一。这是用节目中豪迪刚做完整形手术时所使用的原版模具制作的极少数木偶之一。
There's the boy in the corner over there. Wow. I know, this is sort of my freaking life. It's crazy. 99% Invisible was reported this week by David Weinberg, produced by Jacob Maldonado Medina and edited by Joe Rosenberg. Mix and sound design by Dara Hirsch, music by Swan Real, fact checking by Graham Hayesha. Special thanks to Roberta Chirac and Fresh Air for the use of the Steven Davis interview. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher
那边角落里那个男孩。哇。我知道，这简直就是我的倒霉人生。太疯狂了。《99%隐形》本周由大卫·温伯格报道，雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳制作，乔·罗斯伯格剪辑。混音和声音设计由达拉·希尔什完成，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。特别感谢罗伯塔·希拉克和《新鲜空气》允许使用史蒂文·戴维斯的采访。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗
Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lasha Madon, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Nina Potuck, Sarah Bake, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. I strongly recommend you go check out David Weinberg's experimental podcast, Random Tape. It's sort of a cabinet of auditory wonders and curiosities that David started in the form of, and I am not joking here, a physical audio zine on compact disc in 2006.
约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉沙·马顿、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普赖姆、妮娜·波图克、萨拉·贝克，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。我强烈建议大家去看看大卫·温伯格的实验播客《随机磁带》。它有点像一个听觉奇观和珍奇柜，大卫在2006年以实体音频杂志（CD格式，我没开玩笑）的形式推出了它。
And it's been a favorite of us radio and podcast nerds ever since. Check it out. It's worth your time. 99% Invisible is part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server, which I highly recommend you check out. That's where I'm spending most of my time these days. You can find a link to it and every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
从那以后，它一直是我们广播和播客爱好者的最爱。去看看吧。值得你花时间。《99%隐形》现在是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心北面六个街区的潘多拉大楼。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们，我强烈建议你去看看。这些天我大部分时间都在那里度过了。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到指向它的链接以及《99PI》的每一期往期节目。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。